all right Monty you chose Taylor over
Turner it came down to the final two and
do you think that you might have been
able to be victorious if you would have
took taken Turner to the end I think uh
based off of conversations I've had with
people who had an outside perspective
they're telling me that I would have but
in that moment I felt as though the jury
would have looked at Turner's game and
said his resume outmatched mine and
that's purely what the conversation
would have been about is him taking out
bigger threats to me taking on more
risks even though I made one more
competitions I felt like that's what the
story and the narrative would have been
and he and I thought he would have outed
me in the jury whereas with Taylor I
thought you know if we were looking at
things very objectively from our game I
felt like I had more margin with her but
I completely underestimated her ability
to communicate her journey throughout
this entire summer
um and and how much it resonated not
only with the women in the jury but also
the men in the jury who saw that being a
great representation of season 24 which
completely proud of her very oppressed
and happy before because I said early on
in the season if I was going to lose
somebody I would love to lose to the
first African-American woman of a you
know a winner of Big Brother so that
that was where my head was at
do you think
um although it was late in the game do
you think the show man's kind of clouded
your judgment a little bit
I don't um I don't think so Laura I I
really looked at it very objectively
um okay I think even before you know
things got yeah hot and heavy with
pillar or not you know I I think I was
thinking that sitting next to her would
still be good for my game even after her
winning her HOH
um I felt like it it made sense just
because of Where I Stood with my resume
and the moves in the game so I thought
that things worked out perfectly with me
being able to choose Turner to make that
move solidify things with folks like
Terence Kyle Joseph who probably would
have respected that game move
um but other things had to be taken into
consideration and I overlooked them
when you saw that it was eight to one
and Turner was because
where you got it oh man I I mean yeah a
little bit at the moment but um yeah but
no I I mean I think the the jury and and
everybody who was probably watching felt
what Taylor was saying and um
the again the way she communicated I I
can only imagine how she walks up and
speaks you know in pageants because what
she did tonight was
um
I sat there and I just I looked I said
you know she even said it she was like
everybody who sits next to me on the
Block usually goes home and and lo and
behold that happened to my ass so you
know here we are but um but no it's I I
think she did a great job of
communicating and if it was eight to one
that's completely fine with me
um I'm glad that she won
um so obviously everybody's wondering
where do you guys stand right now
yeah yeah I I'm sure they are uh you
know look I I think for us uh there's a
lot to still be learned about each other
um especially outside of that damn house
you know like there's so many game
influences and you start thinking about
why somebody's doing something doesn't
have to do with the game or is it more
personal is it because cameras are on
like all of this stuff runs through your
mind whereas outside of that I think we
can have a lot more transparent
conversations about
who we both are as people so I think I'm
you know I'm looking forward to those
conversations and you know we're going
to take it step by step from there
over at ET Canada thought it would be a
great idea for Taylor to do a Super Bowl
commercial for chips
um what do you think that would look
like oh my God
I could see her uh
uh I don't know if you guys saw her BB
comic but that would be a pretty
accurate you know animated way of maybe
her having that commercial right where
she's a Superhero just using chips to
fling people you know left and right and
think about people's heads and just you
know defeating crime with with her chip
Powers because she's eating whatever
brand that she has to promote so I think
that could be a good idea but she looks
like she doesn't need any chips I don't
know yeah see Laura this is uh she's one
of those physical anomalies you know as
a fitness professional I I'm like okay
I'm very on it about like my calories
and eating food this this young woman
can eat potato chips all day of day you
know work out maybe once a week and
still maintain that figure it's it's
yeah she's she's blessed I mean I'm
jealous like I could never do that
all right so Turner like to use these
terms bus and discussing way out of not
my generation but I'm learning about it
now yeah so I'm gonna go through uh
different scenarios and I want you to
tell me if they were bussing or
discussing
okay okay okay so living in the Big
Brother house
awesome
uh the BB comics
busting The zingbot Zing
uh I'll say disgusting
so sometimes they were mean they were
pretty mean you know Michael's
unwarranted I
don't think he's ugly dude that was
horrible
[Laughter]
Julie busting super mega busting totally
I agree with you on that one
um Daniel's freak out
disgusting definitely
especially towards me my God
and this one's a bit personal the love
triangle between you Joseph and Taylor
foreign
I did not know that there was some sort
of third leg to this uh the circle or
this triangle here so I I got I gotta
have a conversation with my boy
hopefully we grab some drinks tonight we
make sense of things so yeah I got some
some work to do well I'm so glad you're
entering the real world again getting
getting Clarity on everything it was so
nice to chat with you and
congratulations again you killed it in
this game and it was so nice to watch
you thank you Laura and nice meeting you
as well